so although it wasn't a huge fan of
straw dogs I did get to see it in an
advanced screening and right before the
screening came out a rep who was in
charge of the screening came out was
like so I just will a guys know we're
gonna show you a special eight-minute
preview to David Fincher's The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo and the whole audience
was like oh my god and I was really
excited because they didn't say that
they didn't announce it I didn't hear
about about the fact they were is even
going to be a preview made or released
anywhere and so I got to see it now it's
not online yet so I can't provide you
with a link but I can give you a review
of what I saw let me start off by saying
the trailer does a pretty good job not
spoiling anything because that's what I
was thinking in fact that was almost for
one second
can I leave the theater because the way
trailers are right now you know it is a
really good job of hiding the really
important aspects of the film and
hinting at what the film has underlying
underneath the film looks incredible it
just looks fantastic of course David
Fincher is directing this movie so of
course it looks beautiful it already
looks like where those movies is going
to inspire people to want to make movies
themselves I mean it's just it looks so
great the dialogue was really
interesting the way a Christopher
Plummer and Daniel Craig talked about
this mystery that's brewing it just all
looks so good
I'm telling you that movie is gonna be
fantastic I really think it's gonna be
great it's coming out in December I'm
really looking forward to seeing it also
the main girl of the film she looks
great her acting it man it looks
freaking good I'm serious everyone looks
like they're on the top levels of their
game and this may be the director the
actors the writing everything just looks
so great Christopher Plummer Daniel
Craig I mean come on you get some of
these actors in this movie this thing is
gonna be good I loved the trailer it was
actually better than all of straw dogs
which proceeded afterwards I'm really
looking forward to the film I think you
guys should be too even a trailer comes
out soon tell me what you thought of it
in the comments below if it comes out
the next few days because I don't know
when it's gonna come out but look
forward to it when it does tomorrow I'm
going to see The Lion King 3d and I
don't know how she does it look forward
to those reviews then